yeah so now Brittany Greiner this uh uh
uh a basketball player who went to
Russia to supplement her income uh and
smoked uh what do they find a hashish
yeah but it's the vape pen the vape pen
with a hashish oil so they say and now
we are trading her for a Russian arms
dealer that's a even trade huh WNBA
member for a Russian arms dealer but
whatever we got to get her back she's a
American
we don't want her to come back like out
of warmba remember him that college
student oh yeah he went to North Korea
supposedly he stole a flag like as a
little prank and then his parents you
know he was stuck there and then finally
his parents like oh he's home it's great
and then like literally his sister went
on the plane saw the condition he was in
and ran off the plane screaming it was
horrible it was horrible I mean they
rearranged his teeth and scrambled his
brain over there in North Korea it was
very bad so you don't want Greiner to
come back like that you want her to come
back and uh play in the uh WNBA but
again and I said this on the bonus
episode if we bail you out if we then
enough don't say anything other than
like I want you to be Candace Owens
level patriotic if we trade a Russian
arms dealer for you that's all that's
all I'm asking if we trade a Russian
arms dealer for you and you come back
just be Candace Owens level patriotic I
mean where it's annoying like the first
post should be red white and blue in an
all red white and blue thing singing the
National Anthem like I'm I'm just
telling you just be grateful you're in a
foreign country smoking hash nobody has
to get you but if this corpse Biden
arranges to get you somehow by trading
this whatever high value Russian guy or
supposedly just be happy about it right
just be enjoy it and don't be like
you know don't don't come back and you
know
just just don't just be happy that's all
I'm saying don't don't be negative in
any aspect if you've just been brought
back from Russia I want that to be part
of the deal if the Biden Administration
was smart part of the deal would be
we're bringing you back on the on the
um condition that you are relentlessly
positive about our country no matter
what from here on out you must be
relentlessly positive about the United
States of America even in the face of
mounting evidence to the contrary you
must be the most positive person ever
why because we bailed you out of a
Russian jail whilst at War kind of with
them during a cold war we bailed you out
that's amazing like you can't come back
and start being like how many women were
nominated for best director don't don't
even start with that now
if you come back and start that you got
to go to Russia again
you can come back and have any problems
you just have to chill
if you come back you gotta go you gotta
chill the wife too
and the wife
if you go on Oprah you gotta go you know
what amazes me how great our country is
that's all you do if we trade this
[ __ ] character from die hard so that
you can come back to America and play a
sport no one watches you must at least
be grateful you must at least be
grateful for this I'm telling you